ah i'm gonna be brutally honest right
now
and just say it i don't think my
girlfriend is very attractive
and now that doesn't mean i don't feel
attracted to her i do
feel kind of attracted to her but i just
don't think that her face is
very attractive overall when i got to
the airport
and i met her in person for the first
time
my honest reaction was i felt kind of
disappointed
i knew what she looked like because we
skyped we did video skype
and i saw her photo but you can't really
tell what a person really looks like
just by looking at videos of them
and just by looking at the photos i felt
like the more i looked at her face and
the more time i spent with her
the less i cared about what she looked
like and it felt like the bond was
getting stronger between us and
i was liking her more and more i don't
know it's really confusing
i don't find her physically attractive
but i do feel attracted to her
is that even possible i guess a lot of
people would say
you shouldn't focus on looks or
appearances
and personalities what counts that's
what's important
something that really surprised me was
the day before i left we spent
the day in the shopping complex
underneath skytree in tokyo
and then we went to the hotel at around
seven o'clock
and when we got to the hotel we just we
had
straight away and then we fell asleep
and we we slept from 7pm
until midnight and then we woke up for a
bit
and then we went back to sleep and woke
up at 8am so
we slept a lot and she looked completely
different
compared to the day when we went to eat
sushi where she looks
really tired and really um she looked
terrible because
she looked so sleek deprived and the day
before i left after we slept
for like 12 hours she looked so
different she looked so refreshed and
she looks so much better
yeah when you're tired when you're tired
you look like yeah you ever heard the
phrase
am you look like you look tired it
really means you look like [ __ ] it ever
happened to you
you look tired and you're like i'm good
um okay
and i know it's kind of silly because
obviously people aren't gonna look great
when they're sleep deprived but
she looked so much better after she
slept for a good solid 10 hours
and i think it was at that moment for
the first time during the whole trip
that i looked at her face and i thought
to myself
hey you don't look so bad actually you
look quite nice i know it's pretty
unfair for me to criticize the way she
looks
i'm sorry this videos
you don't look so bad you look quite
nice actually
yeah don't worry about my chat lips
because she's a single parent and she
has a full-time job so it must be a lot
of stress
she must be very tired most of the time
and i had a child of mine and i was a
single parent i wouldn't look like this
you know what's confusing me about this
this doesn't say ex-girlfriend
yeah so she's going to see that but then
again
what is this about just talking about
how his girlfriend's face is not
attractive
oh okay
ah the internet's a weird place man the
internet is
weird bruh what's that do you imagine
like you just log on one day and you're
in your my girl and your girlfriend's
like you know what his people
uh let me talk to y'all about it hi guys
yeah um
[Music]
i'm just so confused i don't understand
if you have that conversation with your
boys
your friends but just blasting that
online i don't i don't it's just so
uncomfortable you know
why am i watching this yeah i think
that's part of it
i just i just i feel like people share
way too much online
and they share too much about things
while still in that relationship
you know like you acknowledge she's
stressed now she's going through stuff
and you think it's a prudent
idea to add on to that stress
by blasting her and saying like she
looks tired and
her face is not that attractive it's
weird because he doesn't seem like an
idiot
right he seems fairly like thoughtful
and you can think things don't mean
but it also seems like do you not have
any awareness do you not recognize how
socially awkward that is no not from
what i see
there's definitely awkwardness well he's
thought about it right like it's not
like he just says she's tired
he's like i understand why she's got a
kid she works long hours so you know
what makes sense that she was sleep
deprived so that's why my initial
reaction so why he's able to
analyze the situation so he has some
measure so why are you here then
why are you here that's what i'm trying
to figure out you understand
i don't understand how a happened but
then b didn't follow
you know what i'm saying no right i know
that's like a [ __ ] who's in the gym but
working out
right you see him pumping weights and
you're like yo man what kind of protein
you take he's like what's protein
powder it's like you're in that gym gym
and you look like arnold like how do you
not know right like
just i don't know it's throwing me off
like you saw go to the horn
yeah going to arnold and saying yo can
you get me that dumbbell what's a
dumbbell
[ __ ] you aren't old there's a whole
competition about
you i don't get it i don't i don't get i
don't get it why it's on the internet i
don't
get it why he was saying that i don't
know why you recorded it why did he post
it
i don't care i don't get why we watched
it there's no insight right there
hey bro i told you when i told you i
don't watch these videos i told you i
don't want i can see
i can think i also like the fact that
she doesn't mind breaking rules when we
was driving back from tokyo
to nagano prefecture she was speeding
pretty much the whole way
the maximum speed limit for the motorway
was about 100
kilometers km but she was driving at 120
130 most of the time which
i found to be pretty funny she's not a
very talkative person we were in the car
together for about two to three hours
and
to be honest we weren't speaking much at
all and i didn't find it awkward or
uncomfortable
i like the fact that we don't have to
speak all the time we can just sit there
in silence and
enjoy each other's company but when you
speak you put it online brother
the more the more the more i'm watching
this
the more irritated i am enjoy each
other's company
and it doesn't feel weird or
uncomfortable i want to talk about
another problem i have
now if you're a human being and you're
watching this i'm not trying to be
offensive when i say this
but i don't find the human race to be
very attractive
in general all right all right yeah yeah
yeah wrap it up wrap it up we're good
yeah in the comments what do they say
they are they're all confused
okay i guess we're all just confused i
think uh i just don't know what i'm
looking at so
confusion
just a pro tip guys pro tip if you feel
some type of way about your significant
other
talk to them or talk to your boys you
know maybe but most of the time talk to
them or don't say anything at all
but don't put it on the internet that's
awkward that's super weak that's why
people got journals write it down that's
a dairy right there
it's not in it it's not it's not meant
for people open up your diary and then
just just just just write you don't have
to open it up and write with a pen you
can just
type maybe this is the future it's the
same cringe as people
like putting random facebook statuses
and doing it
well today i did this that after that
today i did this oh my god
the kids are this they get the desk this
is oh my god this is worse
because at least that one's innocuous
this
could really hurt someone's self-esteem
it's your girlfriend
yeah you know what i mean she wants to
be attractive to you
and you look at her and say your face is
ugly by the way let me get this
megaphone and let everybody probably
including your friends and family know
how i think about it i've seen some
people do that
doing comedy with that my girl is so
stupid oh my boy is so stupid
and then he just blasted on that bro but
hey maybe we missed it that just kind of
threw me for a loop
or maybe this dude you know we got some
wrong we don't know um
if that's the case but yeah that was
interesting
tell us what you guys think in the
comments below would you ever do that to
your significant other
[Music]
foreign